a lot of people like a lot of kids I
didn't know my dad did it work vaguely
knew that he wrote stories but I didn't
think about it I was probably I was 15
the first time I read anything of his
and it was his first book in his only
novel lieutenant and I really loved it
but I couldn't believe my father wrote
something that good because you know
he's just that guy and then the first
short story of his i right i was
probably 18 and it was the story
killings which was ultimately adapted
into the film in the bedroom and I
couldn't believe the power of that story
and so yeah I loved his work I still
loved his work he's one of my favorite
writers I think he's a really honest
passionate compassionate writer I don't
I that the Catholicism is always it
that's foreign to me you know you know
like I don't I don't practice a
particular faith and and that's all but
it'sit's i love i love it work I think
he was an artist
yeah Vonnegut actually when my father
left the Marines moved to you until I
would write his workshop in the 60s some
of my earliest memories were our
grandmother bought us a TV and this guy
Kurt would come down every day at three
o'clock and watch Batman and he chain
smoke and you had curly hair and he
looked down at me and I look up at him
and he'd say I like the Riddler who's
your favorite character you smoke and I
said no I like false face yeah coppell
kazowie and it was Kurt Vonnegut had no
I years later i watch Batman with Kurt
Vonnegut yes you did uh I wouldn't say
well I would say my father's life was
tumultuous and that he was what
sociologists would call a serial
monogamist you know he was married three
times divorced three times and I think
if he lived he'd been married again I
you know he and I talked about some of
this later in his life and I know that
with each marriage he meant to stay
married it just wasn't in the cards for
him so the tumultuous part was really
just the home front you know the nest he
was never quite station
I see any of his running mind not really
well only in that we both uh you know he
he wrote really deep lovely character
driven fiction I try to write
character-driven fiction but I think we
have such a different vision of the
world and I think his sentences were
actually more lyrical and beautiful his
real real stylist and he is from the
south you know that's an important
distinction he's a southern writer at
least in voice I think and in cadence
see a lot of Faulkner and st. James
Bible in him I think and from the
knowing I'm from New England it's a
whole different vibe no I don't think so
i think if we didn't have the same name
no one would ever think of us two
together but i might be wrong I'm just
you know
I read a lot of southern fiction and I
and I think what I love about it is what
i love about all you know all my
relatives from Louisiana my mother and
father every grandparent aunt uncle
cousin everybody's from Louisiana in
Texas too so I feel sort of a soulful
connection to that region although I'm
an East Coast kid you know I'm a mill
town kid from north of Boston I think
that there is a certain lyricism in
southern writing that is not in northern
writing I'm making broad generalizations
here but there's a certain lyrical
quality that I think might come from the
st. James Bible in some ways it comes
from I don't know it's frankly a mystery
but but I love and there's also a deep
sensual quality to a lot of you know and
so much southern writing everybody's got
a body you know there's there there's
bourbon and crawfish and hot Sun on your
face and the squeal of a car over gravel
I'm a sucker for all that I love that
and I'm making broad generalizations but
one could argue that a lot of writing
from the North tends to be a little more
cerebral and urban fast clipped more of
interior sort of life little edgier and
I like both I mean both are delicious
really and I don't know man I am really
thought about this with me I make I'm a
kind of fall somewhere in between I
don't know I think they're equally
powerful I don't believe southern
fiction is any superior to northern
fiction at all and I'm not even
comfortable these broad generalizations
because there are so many exceptions but
there are some some broad truths the
right thing
you